تناولنا في حلقتنا مبارحه خبر عن اللاعب
البرازيلي داني الفيش المتهم بقضيه اغتصاب
وموجود في السجن منذ عشرين يناير بانتظار
محاكمته تطورات قضيته في الامس كانت عن
حالته النفسيه صعبه في السجن وعصبيته
وتوتره ودخوله اضرابا عن الطعام ورفضه
الجلوس مع اي احد من السجناء والسبب
الاخبار المتداوله هو ان زوجته جوانا
سانرس زارته واخبرته بنيتها الانفصال عنه
بشكل نهائي لكن اخبار اليوم متناقضه تماما
مع الاخبار السابقه كان صحيفه سبورت
الاسبانيه كتبت ان داني الفيج بدا يعتاد
على حياه السجن وانشا دوري كره قدم بين
النزلاء وقالت الصحيفه بان طلب النزلاء
على شراء الملابس الرياضيه قد تضاعف اربع
مرات منذ دخول الفيجا السجن والسبب
مباريات كره القدم التي يقيمها الصحيفه
نقلت عن محاميه الفيش تاكيدات ان موكلها
بحاله مزاجيه جيده ومتاقلم مع الاوضاع
داخل السجن وعلاقته طيبه بزملائه النزلاء
في الداخل وانهم حتى يطالبونهم بتوقيع
كثيرا وقالت ايضا انه واثق من برئته
[موسيقى]